Eruptions from a volcano on the Spanish island of
La Palma have intensified, with a new vent opening
up, releasing more lava. More than 400 homes have
been destroyed so far. Ash and dust from the new
fissure have forced the island's authorities
to ground air travel until further notice.
The fiery cauldron of Cumbre Vieja,
spewing livid magma and clouds of ash.
A week of eruptions has created a cone
more than one hundred meters high,
which is now beginning to collapse under
its own weight, unleashing a river of lava.
Residents of La Palma can only watch
and wonder what will come next.
"I am very, very worried about the situation
of the ash, because the ash is blanketing the
neighborhood. It's been a disaster for all
the plants, animals and all the buildings."
A new vent opened over the weekend. It's
feared more homes may be swallowed by lava.
Already hundreds of properties
have been destroyed.
Those evacuated days ago still
cannot return to retrieve belongings.
The island's banana plantations
are also under threat.
Airport workers clear a
blanket of ash from the runway,
though all flights have been suspended.
Tourists are evacuating by sea,
abandoning their holidays, and sparing a
thought for the locals who must stay behind.
"I feel sad for the people
here who are struggling.
We didn't enjoy it the way we should have.
We feel very bad about what is happening."
Scientists say they can't predict how the
lava will flow. The Spanish government plans
to soon designate the island a disaster zone
- making official what is already visible.